you as a musician
so you uh you write your own music you
uh play guitar you sing
um maybe can you give
an overview of the role music is played
in your life
you're one of the you're a world-class
scientist
and so it's kind of fascinating to see
somebody
um in your position who's also a great
musician
and and and uh still loves playing music
yeah well i wouldn't call myself a great
musician like you know one of the best
of all time yeah
that's right but we were saying offline
confidence is like the most essential
thing about that's right exactly
it's the confidence and kind of like
moodiness right yeah
um yeah look i mean music plays
an absolutely essential role in in
everything i do
because i lose if i stop playing
for one reason or another say i'm
traveling i notably
lose creativity in every other aspect of
my life
right there's something i don't
view you know playing music as a
separate endeavor from doing science or
doing doing whatever it's all
it's all part of that same creative
thing
which is distinct from i don't know uh
pressing a button or like you know so
it's not a break from science it's
a part of your science it's absolutely
it's a part of
it's it's i would say you know it's a
thing that enables
the science right the science would you
know
suck even more than it does already uh
without the music
and that means like the creating of the
the writing of the music or is it just
even playing other people's stuff is it
is it yeah it's it's definitely both
um yeah and also just you know
i love uh love to play guitar
love to sing you know my wife tolerates
my uh my screeching singing you know
and uh even kind of likes it so yeah so
people should check out your stuff you
have a great voice so i i love your
stuff
um is there something you're you're
super busy
is there something you could say about
practicing
uh for musicians for guitar for you're
also in a band
so like that whole how you can manage
that is there some tricks
or some hacks to um being a lifelong
musician
while being like super busy so i would
say
you know the way that i optimize
um my life is i try to i try to do
you know the thing that i'm passionate
about in a moment
and put that at the top of the priority
list there are moments when
you know you just you feel inspired to
play music and if you're in the middle
of something if you can avoid
if that can be put on hold just do it
right there are times when you get
inspired about something scientific
um you know i
do my best to drop everything go into
that
you know mode of that isolated mode and
and execute upon that so it's a chaotic
you know i i think i have a pretty
chaotic lifestyle where
i'm always doing kind of multiple things
and jumping between
uh between what i'm doing but at the end
of the day
it's it's not like um
you know those those moments of
inspiration
are actually kind of rare right like
most of the time
all of us are just doing kind of uh
doing the stuff that get that needs to
get done if you
do the disservice to yourself of saying
oh i'm inspired to
you know do this calculation and figure
it figure this out
but i've gotta answer email or just like
do something
something silly uh you know that is a
um that is nothing more than the service
and also
like i have some social media presence
but i i mostly stay off of you know
social media
to you know just frankly because like i
don't kind of
i don't enjoy the mental cycles that it
uh that yeah it robs you of that
the yeah yeah those those precious
moments
that could be filled with inspiration in
your in your other pursuits
um but there's something to maybe you
and i are different in this like i
i tried to play at least 10 uh minutes
of guitar every day
like almost on the technical side yeah
like
keeping that base uh of
of basic competence going and
i mean the same way like writers will
get in front of a paper no matter what
that kind of thing it just feels like
that
for my life has been essential to to do
the daily ritual of it otherwise days
turn into weeks weeks turn to months and
you haven't played guitar for
months no no i i i understand for me
i think it's it's been like if we have a
gig coming up
we will definitely need deadlines yeah
yeah that's right no like we
we will uh we will sharpen up uh
definitely you know especially coming up
too good it's like
you know we're not trying to make money
with this this is like
just for the uh for that satisfaction of
doing something doing something well
right um but overall
i would say most i play guitar most days
right most days and you know when i put
kids to sleep
i i play guitar you know with them and
we like
just make up random songs about you know
about our cat or something you know like
we just
do kind of random stuff but you know
music is always involved in that process
you